con un mensaje de tranquilidad en medio
de la crisis oryzon son aprovechar la
vitrina de la conferencia del partido
conservador para dar a conocer una
reforma radical para el país que incluye
cambios en el sistema migratorio con el
objetivo de abordar la desigualdad
regional y poner fin a lo que definió
como debilidades estructurales a largo
plazo de la economía
james y después de décadas de deriva y
vacilación este gobierno reformador que
logró el 'break' sit y que está
alcanzando el lanzamiento de la vacuna
contra el hobbit va a lograr la atención
social y vamos a tratar los problemas
subyacentes de nuestra economía y
sociedad los problemas que ningún
gobierno ha tenido agallas para abordar
antes el discurso de johnson se presenta
en medio de una de las peores crisis de
desabastecimiento donde los ciudadanos
deben hacer largas filas para llenar sus
tanques de combustible la situación es
una consecuencia de la escasez de mano
de obra que provocó la salida del reino
unido de la unión europea algo que el
premier defendió y entonces estamos
embarcando en el cambio de dirección que
estaba pendiente desde hace mucho en la
economía de reino unido no vamos a
volver al viejo modelo roto con bajos
salarios bajo crecimiento pocas
habilidades y baja productividad
todo ello asistido por una emigración
descontrolada
aunque en forma grave a pesar de ello la
publicación británica de cualquier
afirma que un sector del empresariado y
los sindicatos rechazan la iniciativa
por considerar que carece de políticas
para impulsar el crecimiento